>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary Quattlebaum: You
know we all know him well,
everybody in this room, we know
his face, his voice, his words,
he's the news director and
lead anchor of EWTN News.
The news division of Eternal
Word Television Network,
Global Catholic Television Network.
He has written bestselling books
about Mother Angelica and I grew
up with a mom who loved and quoted
Mother Angelica as did my husband.
Let's see, but what we're
really here for today is
to celebrate Raymond's new
childrens adventure series
about a 12 year old
guy named Will Wilder.
And trying saying Will Wilder really
quickly, it's almost impossible.
I think he must have done that
to the people that are going
to be reading your
books out loud right?
The first book is Will Wilder,
The Relic of Perilous Falls
and it's being compared to
Rick Riordan's Percy Jackson
and the Olympians series,
which is high praised.
It's full of danger and daring do.
Will is the Indiana Jones of the
middle school crowd and Dave Berry
and we all listen to Dave
Berry called the book a wild
and thrilling tale.
Raymond's second book comes
out next spring Will Wilder,
The Lost Staff of Wonder.
The reviewed journal book
list praised the relic
of Perilous Falls saying it had
a likeable cast of characters,
plenty of suspense and
battles between good and evil.
So I really looking forward to
hearing Raymond talk about his ideas
for getting the book,
where the series might go,
after the first two books, so join
me in welcoming Raymond Arroyo.
[ Applause ]
>> Raymond Arroyo:
And you got the tongue
and you even the tongue
twister right.
I know it's a challenge.
Hi everybody, thank
you all for coming out.
I, this series started in a odd
way, though some of you know me
from television I'm a
journalist by trade.
Which means I run around
telling everybody else's stories.
But this has allowed me
to go to places that most
of us don't ever get to go.
Into catacombs, into
secret chambers,
into vaults that haven't been
opened in centuries or seen
by people in many many years.
And all of that was kind of working
in the back of my mind and because
of my children, we have three
children, parents often end
up telling their kids stories
and I told my children
stories at bath time.
So I often say Will Wilder was born
as a soap opera, which is true.
I would tell the stories, oh I
love, you're so good at this.
I could watch her, see
this is very distracting
because I'd be watching
you and not me.
I'm going to stand over here.
But she's much better
at this than I am.
What I love about the
series is it really was born
for children and because
of children.
My kids often had difficulty moving
from one phase of bathing
to the next.
So to get them to dry off and
then to brush their teeth and then
to comb their hair, I would
create these little stories
and it was about a wacky family.
A 12 year old kid who
was an adventurer,
a little bit of a rule
breaker, just a little bit.
And he would often find
himself getting into trouble
by exploring things that
he had questions about,
which I think we all do at
some point in our lives.
So, I would, I started telling,
he wasn't Will Wilderthen,
he a very different name, if you
think Will Wilder was hard Mary,
you should have heard the
original name aah, Carmen Derman.
The minute Random House signed the
contract they said we love the story
except you got to change the
kids name, so I went away
and found something better.
Will Wilder's actually a
great name for this character.
Because he has a very strong will
and anybody know what a wilder is?
Do you know what a,
it's an occupation.
Do you know what a wilder is?
Nobody. A wilder is one who captures
or kills wild animals or beasts.
As you read the story
you'll discover why
that is the perfect name, not only
for Will but for his whole family.
So that's where the family was
born and kind of the characters
but I didn't quite have a spine.
You know as authors we want to
have a spine to hang the story on.
A direction, what is
this really about?
So I was traveling with my
boys, we were in Dublin Ireland.
And I was working on a
PBS special and it was
at a church called the Christ
Church Cathedral, it's in the middle
of Dublin, it's a beautiful
old church,
it really looks like an old castle.
I mean to some of you it would
look like a mini hog warts,
it's kind of got spires
and it extends out
and it's got several buildings
attached, really neat place.
Well, the night before we went to
shoot at this particular cathedral,
we had a sight survey,
where you go and kind of set
out the cameras and
get things ready.
And as I left the hotel, on the
cover of the Irish Newspaper,
it said, Relic of Laurence O'Toole
stolen from Christ Church Cathedral.
Well. The journalist in me, did that
and then I said well this
might make a great story
for the children series
I'm working on.
So I went to investigate and when
I got there, there was a cage
and it was probably 30 feet off
the ground in the cathedral.
And bolted on to the
wall was this cage
and inside was this 700 year old
heart of Saint Laurence O'Toole,
now I had never heard
of Laurence O'Toole,
I thought he maybe was
related to Peter O'Toole,
but I had no idea who he was.
So I asked this little caretaker,
a sacristan what had happened.
And he said oh they broke in in
the night, they had a ladder.
They climb the ladder and they
use wire cutters, cut the cable,
cut the blasted thing off
the wall and ran off with it.
I said well, do you
know where it is?
Have you found out, any ideas?
No we don't know where it is.
Well to this day the heart
of Laurence O'Toole
has not been returned.
So somewhere, maybe in Dublin,
is this 700 year old
heart of Laurence O'Toole.
But it got me thinking.
What if that 12 year old kid that
I'd been telling my children about,
who became Will Wilder,
what if he had a good reason
to borrow or snatch a relic?
And what if it had the supernatural
powers that so many believed it had?
Well that was kind of the
beginning of the story.
And from there I stretched it out,
I enlarged some of the characters.
I have always been
fascinated, not only by
and I love childrens literature,
I mean I am one of those adults
that goes back to kids lit.
I find it not only nostalgic but I
think it's life giving, the wisdom
and the humanity of who we
are I think of contained
in the stories we pass on.
Particularly those
we give to children.
And so CS Lewis had that great line,
if a 50 year old can't read a
childrens book it's not a very good
childrens book and I agree.
So I tried to write a story here
that would appeal to all ages
and that children could
rediscover later in life,
as an adult which I think
the best childrens books do.
So this is a multigenerational tale
as well as a multicultural one.
You have Will Wilder, I'll
tell you the basic plot.
Will is a 12 year old who has,
since he was very small,
since he was about five.
He's been seeing shadows out
of the corner of his eye.
And on his 12th birthday these
shadows begin to take shape.
And he can't quite figure
out what it is he's seeing.
His brother breaks his arm
in a backyard accident
and Will is to blame.
And so while he's punished for two
weeks digging, literally digging
and planting trees, he discovers
that his great grandfather
had created this museum
at the center of Perilous Falls.
And in it the great grandfather
collected antiquities and relics,
many of which really exists,
in fact all of those mentioned
in the book you can actually find.
In institutions, in
library's, in churches,
in museums all over the world.
So I liked that idea, using
real things that existed.
So Will decides he's going
to break into the museum
with some of his friends.
Liberate the relic, borrow it,
touch it to the arm of his brother,
heal his brothers arm,
return the relic
and he'll get out of his punishment.
Makes sense, yes?
Things don't quite work
out that way for Will.
He unleashes an ancient
evil, the flood waters
around Perilous Falls begin to rise,
monsters, unspeakable monsters start
to emerge all over town
and Will is really to blame
and the clock is ticking.
And it really takes Will and
his great aunt Lucille and many
of her friends to try to chase
down this relic and who has it.
Now Will unwittingly and I won't
ruin to much of the book for you,
but Will unwittingly hands the relic
over to someone he should
never hand it over to.
And what I love about the series
and in so many of the letters,
the thing that's been
most gratifying.
Is, mothers and kids, grandmothers
and grandfathers and kids,
uncles and kids have been
experiencing the book together
and it speaks to them
on two different levels.
But it really is a family
saga, it is not about an orphan
or a kid alone or you know he
goes off and leaves everybody
and you know decides he's
going to remake the world.
The whole wacky dysfunctional family
goes on the adventure with him,
which I like because I come from
a wacky dysfunctional family.
So it all makes sense.
There's also a lot of
wisdom and fun in between.
I often say he's sort of Indiana
Jones meets Dennis the Menace
in the Exorcist but, I'll
let you figure that out.
I was talking to my
daughter earlier, we were,
somebody had mentioned to
her about Indiana Jones.
They read the book and
they thought wow this is
like a young Indiana Jones.
And I told Mariella I ran
into the real Indiana Jones
at the Four Seasons Hotel
in Georgetown not long ago.
It was not a great moment I have
to say, you know you'd expect,
it was Harrison Ford,
it wasn't Indiana Jones,
but to me that's Indian Jones.
And he came wondering in and I'm
standing there I'm in this suit,
so I guess he thought
I worked there.
So he comes up to me and you know
I'm, I've got a big smile on my face
and he walks up and I say oh my
god my kids would do anything
to trade places with me right now.
And he said thanks, do you
know where the bathroom is?
I said well I think it's back there,
is the restaurant back there to?
I said you're Indiana Jones you're
suppose to know these things,
yeah it's that way, right there.
Can you show me?
I said I don't work here, but
yeah I'll show you come on.
So I got take Indiana Jones to the
bathroom, that's my claim to fame.
Oh, he found the lost arc
of the covenant you know,
now he found the bathroom,
so some things come harder.
What? Get him on the
show, yeah well I,
there's some things
we shouldn't show.
You know Indy should
have some privacy.
But I loved writing this, I
loved going on this journey,
I've spoken to 10,000 kids plus
around the country about this book.
And to watch them come alive in
this world, has been amazing.
So many of them, it's like their
own little private da Vinci codes,
I've been getting pictures that the
kids have sent me while on vacation
because as I said, the reliquaries,
the relics, some of the antiquities,
the sarcophagi mentioned
in the book,
you can find at the
Walter's museum at the MET,
at the Miami Museum of Art.
All over the country and the world
at the Louvre, at the Vatican I
like that idea that it's grounded
in something permanent and real
because at it's heart, what
this story is really about,
is how and one of the characters
says this to Will at one point.
Unless you know your past, you'll
never really discover your future.
And I think that's true.
The decisions of our forefathers
and foremothers really
do light our path,
we're part of a much
longer saga and story.
And so I love that it's a bigger
story than even I intended.
I just finished the second book,
I'm working on the third book.
The second book is called Will
Wilder, The Lost Staff of Wonders
and there's a particular
artifact that is in the museum
that goes missing and
Will is blamed.
He didn't do it this time.
But the problem is he doesn't
know who took it either.
And, well I won't ruin it for
you, but it's a lot of fun,
it really has a great engine to it
and moves along at a great clip.
If you all have any questions
I'd love to take your questions,
they have mics on the aisles there.
Feel free to jump up and it,
you know I love being able,
not only to share Will's
story but it really ends
up being all of our stories.
Because I personally
believe and I've seen it,
we are detached from
our own history.
Not only our own family histories
but our history as a people.
And it's neat to weave
in these touchstones,
you know you have the African
American Museum opening
as we stand here today.
Those touchstones of the
past instantly take us back
to that moment.
And there's something
important about us as a people.
Holding on to those
things and cherishing them
and realizing what they represent.
Not only the struggle but
the promise contained there.
And of course with these relics
I get to, I get the added bonus
of having supernatural possibilities
that I can play with because some
of these relics are reported
to have certain properties.
In the case of Saint Tom
the, bones of Saint Thomas,
which I use in the first
book, there were two things
that it supposedly could do.
The bones of Saint Thomas, heal
and the Indian Church believed
it held the flood waters back
from the cathedral where
his relics are interred.
So I use both of those things in
my story and it kind of informs
around the edges what happens
to Will and leads you back
to the thing itself and the much
bigger story that I think is
as fascinating as anything
I've written.
So questions?
I know I, I ask for questions and
then I started chattering away.
Come on there's a microphone here.
Don't be shy.
I only bite after two
o'clock, oh look at the time.
No, no the microphones
there, look right there.
He's walking right up, he wants
to make a this a double act.
>> Make a movie.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Make a movie.
A movie of what?
>> Will Wilder.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Okay you want
to make a Will Wilder
movie, I will tell you.
I'm talking to some people now.
We've just got get the right deal.
You don't want me to just sign
rights away that's never good.
I want to be involved, but we'll,
I promise you we're working
at making Will a movie.
But I want you to read
all the books first.
>> Okay.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Okay.
Is that it?
>> Yeah.
>> Raymond Arroyo: That's all.
Nothing else?
Okay. Thank you for coming.
Yes sir?
>> Why don't you make a
Will Wilder comic book?
>> Raymond Arroyo: A Will Wilder
comic book, you know a friend
of mine who works at one
of the comic book companies
has approached me.
Let me get a few more books into
the series and then we'll do that.
Because then you'll cheat
and read the graphic novel.
Which in my day it was
called a comic back
and you won't read the book,
I want you to read the book.
>> I love comic books.
>> Raymond Arroyo: You do?
Why do you like comic books?
>> Because they're superheros.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Well there are
things you can do in comic books
that you can't do with
the written word.
But then your imagination is,
I make you work a little harder
in the book, but it's a fun ride.
Okay? Yes sir or whoa
this lady here, sorry.
Yes ma'am?
>> Hi do you believe some
of the supernatural powers
that you write about?
>> Raymond Arroyo: Do I
believe in some of them?
I've seen some of, I've
seen some pretty bizarre
and spectacular things around
some of this, there's phenomena
that is associated with
some of these things.
So there's a part of
me that looks at it
and says there's something
happening there.
>> Okay.
>> Raymond Arroyo: You know
I've consulted with a lot
of not only librarians and
teachers writing this project.
Because I wanted to find out what
kids were really interested in,
what they were looking for
and I think there's a big
opening here that I saw.
That I think particularly
boys and girls they want to go
on an adventure, but they want
something that is grounded
in the world, something a little
scary but not gory and horrible.
And something that can give you some
broader life lessons that you can,
you know after going on
the journey you're left
with a resonance of something real.
I also consulted with people
scientists who experimented
and examined a lot of the
supernatural phenomena
around certain places or items and
their research helped me a lot.
And I've woven some
of that in between.
So yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Thank you.
Yes sir?
>> What power would you choose
to have if you could have any
of the brotherhood powers?
>> Raymond Arroyo: Oh
what power would I have?
I'd probably want to have, I think
I'd want to have Will Wilder's gift.
Will sees things nobody else can.
He sees through that invisible veil
that I think is all around us here.
He can see good, he can see evil,
very clearly in concrete form.
I'd like to have that.
I think I've met a lot of people
that Will is probably already seen.
He's just seen them in a
clearer form than I have.
So yeah I'd like that
ability I think.
To see deeper, I think we all
need to see a little deeper.
Yes ma'am?
>> Can we see any of the principles
of your faith in your books?
>> Raymond Arroyo: You know I write
the books to entertain, I really do.
My first obligation is to entertain
and to take kids on an adventure.
So you know my beliefs they,
certainly these items I'm dealing
with they're rooted in belief
as Steven Spielberg rooted the
Indiana Jones series in belief.
As Rick Riordan, you know that's
Greek mythology and belief.
So this is a different sandbox.
But I think we approach
it the same way.
It's really to go on a great
adventure and to learn something
in the doing about us as people.
But it's not, I wouldn't call
it a faithful book or book
in any way trying to advance faith.
I told the lady the
other day, who came to me
and said you know I won't let
my kids read Harry Potter,
I said why not?
She said well I'm afraid
they're going to be witches,
I said please your
children are no more going
to be witches reading J K Rowling
than they'll become you know
Catholic reading my book, it's just.
>> But probably what I wanted to ask
you is, is it any goal that you have
in terms of lessons for kids
or something you want to?
>> Raymond Arroyo: Yeah.
I think all good literature from
Tolkien to J K Rowling to Kipling,
it all has a certain
intact morality about it.
Because it's true to
the nature of the world
and that sometimes disappoints,
that sometimes agitates
but there's these eternal truths
that I think childrens
literature has always been a great
reservoir of.
I certainly want to
continue that tradition,
but it's not anything sectarian.
I mean anybody can and I've been
delighted the letters I've gotten
from so many people.
You know all over the globe but
particularly in the United States
from different backgrounds
and they all,
it hits them at different
places and in different ways.
Which is what was intended,
it's a universal tale.
Yes sir?
>> Hi.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Hi.
>> Interesting presentation
thank you very much.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Thank you.
>> I'm curious, how do you think
childrens literature and the act
of writing and the act of publishing
distribution and the work product,
how do you think it's changed
over the last 50 years or so?
>> Raymond Arroyo: Oh well,
I mean look the market
has certainly become,
the business is more
lively than ever before.
The children sections is
probably the most traffic section
of any bookstore.
I personally think it's because the
literature there is the richest.
It's, you know it's both
wondrous and it takes us
out of our everyday life, it also
roots us in the reality of what
that life is about I think.
That's what good childrens
literature should do.
We're shaping in many
ways young people
for the experiences
they're about to encounter.
And you're hopefully are doing
it in an imaginative, fun,
engaging way that makes them
want to go down those paths.
But I find so many adults,
adult friends of mine,
I mean I've always been a kids lit
fanatic, but a lot of my friends,
people here in DC, it is their
retreat, it is the valve they use
to sort of get away from the
work a day and if they're going
to spend time in a fictional
universe, they'd rather do it
in kids lit because it's
broader, it's a little wider.
You can do more there.
It's fantastical but it's very true.
It's simple but it's deep and wise.
So I think that's what
has driven many adults to,
I mean half of the readers of YA
and even some kids lit,
they're 18 and older.
So that tells you something
about us as a people,
it also tells you something
about the state
of literature broadly speaking.
That people are going
to kids lit now.
>> And then one quick followup?
How can I make this
little young lady read,
but not think it's a chore to read?
>> Raymond Arroyo: Read to her.
Read to her often and I'm going
to tell you a little trick
that a teacher of mine pulled.
I was not a great reader.
And in 5th grade, I had a teacher
and he would read us
Ellery Queen mysteries.
Nobody even knows who
Ellery Queen is anymore,
it's like something
in a distant past.
You read Ellery Queen?
Wow. Ellery, the little girl
behind you reads them to.
Ellery Queen was, it was
actually mystery writing team,
but they wrote these very
addictive kind of mysteries.
Well he would read us Ellery
Queen mysteries and he'd get right
up until the murder, okay.
And I can always remember the
story, it was in front of a hotel
and these dignitaries I
shouldn't even say this,
these dignitaries were coming out
and they were just dropping dead
and nobody could figure out why.
And as it turns out Ellery Queen
is there, he goes over this head
of state is just falling and
he finds a curare laced dart
in the neck of this head of state.
And this teacher closed the book,
put it on the end of his desk
and said, if you all would
like to know the rest
of the story you may come
up and check the book out.
Well we were like, ah
everybody killing each other
to get to the book.
You want to know what happens.
So I went out of my with this series
and the second book even more so.
To create a lot of cliffhangers
within the cliffhangers,
which takes a lot of trouble.
But because I want the kids to keep
reading and there's no obligation
for anyone to read your book.
You've got to make
them want to read.
So, start reading a
really good story,
not only mine there are
other great stories.
Up until the climax, up until
that cliffhanger and then stop
and she'll read the rest.
Everybody wants to
know what happens.
Everybody.
I was at a school district in New
Orleans, a very poor school district
and a friend of mine donated
150 books to all the kids there.
These were not kids that read
regularly, they didn't like to read,
the principle told me
I don't know what kind
of reception you're going to get.
But they gave the books out to
the kids a week before I came.
Well when I get there, the kids
books looked like they'd been
to a war, they were bent back
and there was scrawling on them,
they were dog eared,
they were loved books.
These kids had really
read these books.
And the principle came over and
said, this is the first book
that some of these children have
ever read from cover to cover.
Well that made my week.
Because you want them to get
into the habit of reading
and the first question
I got from all of them,
when is the next book coming?
You know many of them
had read it twice.
So that is I really do believe
if you give a child a great story
they'll want to know how it ends.
But you've got to give them
the opportunity and lot's
of opportunities because
the things you
like might not be where
their tastes are.
Let them go select their own books.
90% of kids who select their
own books, will read it.
90%. Then Barnes and Noble
didn't even pay me to say that.
Yes ma'am?
>> Do you know how many books
you're going to have in the series?
>> Raymond Arroyo: How
many books in the series?
I have outlined seven books.
I've written 2 1/2.
We'll try to get to seven, it's
a big story and there are a lot
of what I love about it it's
almost like peeling back an onion
and you find out something
about this character
and then it reveals something else.
But why the museum is where it is?
Why Will's great grandfather
built it?
Why his aunt Lucille has
been so kind of shunned
from the rest of the family?
All those things come
out as the series goes on
and what happened to
his grandfather?
His grandmother?
We don't anything about them.
You learn more about
that as series goes on.
And I love that it's
also drawn all of us kids
to ask their parents what
about my grandfather?
I had a beautiful lady send
me a note the other day.
She and her daughter were
reading the book and she ended
up telling her daughter the story
of her great grandfather
who was a rabbi.
And how he got out of the
country and saved the family.
She didn't know any of this.
It's important for us
to tell those stories,
our own stories to one another.
And that was a big part of this too.
So six more coming.
Preorder now.
Thank you.
Yes ma'am?
>> When did you know that
you wanted to be a writer?
>> Raymond Arroyo: When did I
know I wanted to be a writer?
You know I think it was
when I was in 5th grade
and fell in love with stories.
I fell in love with mysteries first
and then I got into treasure island
and I read all of the Agatha
Christie novels, I read Rex Stout,
Conan Doyle, all the
Sherlock Holmes stories.
So I would get lost in those worlds,
that's when I knew
I wanted to write.
And then I you know, then I
kind of bounced around, I wrote,
I was a writer I wrote as
a journalist and then I got
into television and now I kind
of see it coming full circle,
cause these are very visual tales.
So, so start writing
and keep writing.
Okay. Thank you all
so much, very quickly
and then I'll answer it over here.
>> My daughter says no
spoilers but we're wondering
if you have any tidbits to give
to your fans to look forward to?
>> Raymond Arroyo: The next book?
>> Maybe or.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Okay Will
Wilder in the Lost Step of Wonders
and I know [inaudible] is going
to throw something at
me if I don't finish.
The Lost Staff is the staff of Moses
which as you know controlled the
plagues in the Old Testament.
That gets stolen.
I'm not saying anymore.
>> Thank you.
>> Raymond Arroyo: Thank you
all it's been a pleasure.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us a loc.gov.